joining me now live from the border town
of sierra vista
arizona sheriff mark lamb of penal
county arizona
sheriff welcome chef mark daniels of
coach county
arizona sheriff welcome sheriff tony
childress of livingston county illinois
welcome and the sheriff sam page of
rockingham
county north carolina you are all
welcome here
sheriffs and you're all with the protect
america now
supporting our sheriffs and law
enforcement you've got a big
job right now and you can go to
protectamericannow.com for more
information
everybody watching when this interview
is over and learn more
about what they're facing but let's get
a first hand account of it
so sheriff lamb you and i talked as you
were pulling this group together about a
week or so ago
tell me what you've learned there at the
border and what the public immediately
needs to know
i think the biggest thing that we've
learned which is why we have sheriffs
here from
north carolina and illinois is this is
not a border problem
just for arizona or texas or new mexico
or california
this is an america problem the fact that
these sheriffs came all the way here
to help us address this issue shows you
the impact it has on their communities
as well
sheriff daniels i want to ask you a
direct question about what our reporter
was just saying
casey stegall was talking about putting
children in harm's way and what they're
seeing in texas is they'll just throw
them right in the river
and then that distracts agents how
difficult is that kind of behavior by
the cartels
to curtail and and to fight in this
whole process
well thank you harris and thanks for
having us on thanks to my sheriffs for
being here
this is the largest humanitarian issue
on the southwest border
going on right now when it comes to what
the cartels are exploiting these people
these children
and then you look at the public safety
aspect of this that's affecting
all communities in america and i'll just
say this harris to you
in this region the tucson sector of
border patrol in this fiscal year
we've had 60 000 getaways just in
this sector of the border that's the
largest in the country
and these are people we've seen on
cameras that have got away that are now
in communities
that should be uh alarming to every
american out there
uh okay so that brings us to
sheriff's childress and and paige uh
sheriff childress i'll come to you first
60 000 getaways and they're fanning out
all over the country
again sheriff lamb is right this isn't
just about the border
good morning harrison thank you for
sponsoring us
and thank you to the sheriffs here for
having me
yes with numbers like 60 000 and numbers
like 172
000 uh coming in
it's absolutely ludicrous that we have
an administration
that refuses to do anything and then
you know last night i understand the
state of the union speech
that he put it on congress
you know saying that his first day
he he asked them to send him a bill
well uh you know we've seen instances
where we had a president that didn't uh
wait to uh wait on congress to pass a
bill
he took action himself and that's what
you know we
expect a leader a true leader
to do is take action
we see that we're putting lives at risk
citizens at risk border patrol agents at
risk
it's it's just a risk for everybody and
then you bring
children and throw them in the river and
drop their mobile
phones risking them as well yes
absolutely sheriff paige i'm going to
come to you next i want to show the
audience something first
a recent fox news poll finds that nearly
half of people think the border
situation
is worse than it was two years ago 56
percent
majority believe biden the president
winning the election is completely or
mostly behind
the surge of migrants at the border
uh first of all sheriff paige i want to
get an idea from you your top line
thoughts
in reaction to that and then i have a
quick follow-up for you
okay well first of all being from north
carolina i see real
now that we have something in common
with arizona and this is real
we have coyotes like they do and we have
mexican drug cartels
in our communities nearly two two days
uh
the violence the crime uh the the
criminal activity
or in our communities and each day
across north carolina
we lose people to heroin and fentanyl or
dying in our communities
we know where the products coming from
but just like we said with the president
mr president
come to the border mr president support
the local
state and federal law enforcement across
this community
and do something and also the cartel we
don't mention them a lot
but i'll tell you this they're the
persons making the money they're the
person capitalizing on the human
smuggling
human trafficking and the crime activity
and the drugs that are taking lives
every day in america
if we fail to secure our borders every
sheriff in america will become a border
sheriff
wow sheriff flame i'm going to give the
follow-up to you
on the numbers that we just showed our
audience on how people are
looking at this and seeing it get worse
and and while the white house and the
bite administration may not want to call
it a crisis across the board
people in america see what's going on
what are your thoughts
absolutely they see what's going on we
hear it every day they're clamoring for
our help i've got community members i'm
70 miles off the border
they say they can't even leave their
kids to watch their younger kids
because of the the people coming in
their carport trying to open their doors
this is a dangerous situation we as
sheriffs are standing together with
protect america now please check it out
at protectamericanow.com
we hear the people's voices we're going
to do our job
they didn't hear what they needed to
hear last night from the president we
had
we expected to hear more we didn't get
that from him and that shows you
this presidency doesn't care about
what's happening here but the sheriff's
do and we're going to continue to stand
up for
the people and for america
you know i have one final question for
you and i'll come to you sheriff daniels
on this
the morale among law enforcement has
been something that i have hit pretty
hard
during this hour of programming on fox
news it's important that we have you all
doing what you're doing and that you
feel supported i would say equally so
for the border patrol which is part of
why you're there you're shoring them up
what are you seeing that they are most
dealing with the border patrol that you
want to jump in and help right away
well harris that's that's a good point
because the morale
the border patrol agents i've spoke to
all the way up to senior leadership
uh is challenged right now there's no
doubt about it their hands are tied
from doing the job they're doing that
secure this border and keep this country
safe
and when you do that you're going to
take the morale away and i'm telling you
the impact
local law enforcement state law
enforcement it's it's a
collective effort and i tell you after
last night's uh
speech by the president it was an insult
for everybody wearing a badge trying to
protect this border
sheriff lamb from left to right here on
screen sheriff daniels sheriff childress
and
sheriff page thank you so very much some
of you coming from pretty far away to
that border
to give us a firsthand look and also
help
thank you for your time gentlemen thank
you harris thank you
thank you thank you america god bless
you too